[Music]
this week's picks include a serious
biopic a not so serious not so biopic
plus a Sci-Fi comedy flick the return of
a very popular TV show now in
mini-series form and a horror movie to
get all caught up in Rotten Tomatoes is
here to support all barberheimer ticket
holders on this week's what to watch
we're in a race against the Nazis
[Music]
have a bomb don't sleep on this Buzzy
biopic that's hitting theaters called
Oppenheimer plenty of reasons to check
this one out but let's start with the
cast led by Killian Murphy as J Robert
Oppenheimer a theoretical physicist who
is considered the father of the atomic
bomb he's joined by names like Emily
Blunt Matt Damon Rami Malek Robert
Downey Jr Josh Hartnett and Kenneth
Brana in supporting roles atomic bomb
talk about cast bomb another reason to
give this one a look is that it was
written produced and directed by
Christopher Nolan and based on a 2005
biography called American Prometheus
Nolan wrote the script in the first
person the first time he's done that to
really put people in oppenheimer's shoes
and he was one of the first ones to
dabble in IMAX black and white
photography for this to help add to the
effect the man's an innovator and now
that the critics have been unsilence we
can report to you that Oppenheimer is
officially certified fresh at 93 on the
Tomato Meter and critics are describing
it as Oppenheimer marks another and
grossing achievement for Christopher
Nolan that benefits from Murphy's toward
the force performance and stunning
visuals it's the best day ever it is the
best day ever and so is yesterday and so
is tomorrow an everyday
[Music]
thinking about dying
also in theaters is probably bringing a
little bit more pink to the screen than
Oppenheimer is Barbie this may not be
the first film based on the popular toy
line from our childhoods but it could be
the most intriguing in part because of
director and co-writer Greta Gerwig and
the unique PG-13 approach she has taken
to the material I mean just when we
thought we knew what was happening they
dropped Ken Singh on us and if Greta
Gerwig is reason one to unbox his Barbie
reasons number two through a million is
the Epic cast led by Margot Robbie as
Barbie and Ryan Gosling as Ken I could
read you a bunch more names again or you
could search for the amazing movie
posters each character got but how about
Issa Rae do a Lipa John Cena and Kate
McKinnon to name a few and Helen Mirren
as the narrator okay I'm done reason a
million and three to go rollerblading
with this Barbie other than just the
crazy visuals and mind tickling
Nostalgia is that it's officially
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter at
89 and honestly childhood you'd be so
proud of you for going to see this one
what that was but that wasn't me
somebody is conducting experiments on us
[Music]
another theater option is the Sci-Fi
comedy they clone Tyrone first and
foremost we gotta point out the cast for
this one are you sensing a theme this
week yeah you're definitely sensing a
theme this one Stars John boyega to Yona
Paris and Jamie Foxx with Kiefer
Sutherland and David Alan Greer also
showing up and supporting roles along
with a strong cast is a fun unique
mystery premise about an unlikely Trio
boyega Paris and fox that ends up
unearthing a government cloning
conspiracy so you know it might have a
little bit of truth behind it plus they
cloned Tyrone was directed by Joel
Taylor in his feature debut which we
always love supporting he also co-wrote
the screenplay something he's pretty
good at after doing it for movies like
Creed 2 and the new LeBron movie
shooting stars on peacock the movie is a
strong 97 fresh on the Tomato Meter with
37 reviews and Counting I'm Deputy U.S
Marshal Rayland Givens and I'm offering
salvation talk to me come on face to
face I am not open
nope making his glorious return to your
TV is the one and only Raylan Givens and
Justified City primeval this mini-series
continues the story from Justified and
is similarly based on the fictional
writing of Elmore Leonard of course the
original Justified series wasn't just
good we're talking six certified fresh
Seasons with three of them at 100 and
nothing below 93 dude so that would be
reason number one to watch this one
justifiably so see what I did there
anyway the second reason is that Timothy
Oliphant is back to fill the Hat of
Givens a role that earned him an Emmy
nod for lead actor in a drama series now
15 years removed from the hollers of
Kentucky Givens lives in Miami but finds
himself taking care of some business in
Detroit where things escalate quickly if
you really need a third reason to dive
back into Justified how does certified
fresh at 93 on the Tomato Meter so far
sound to you the consensus from critics
says that oliphan's quick draw charm
shows no signs of dulling in City
primeval and introspective and very
welcome return for RaeLynn Givens can't
wait I heard it again
no more nightmares tonight great champ
[Music]
is getting ridiculous
and finally bringing the scare factor to
our list and to theaters is the horror
flick cobweb sticking with our theme of
great cast this week this one Stars the
great Lizzie Kaplan and Anthony Starr
the latter of which has been killing it
and lots of people on the boys another
reason to weave your way into this movie
is that the premise is extra creepy it's
about a young boy who hears a constant
tap tap from inside his wall but nobody
believes him been their kid been there
it's also worth noting that producers
for cobweb include Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg two guys who seem to always be
producing quality stuff and it features
a first time director and Samuel Bowden
directorial debuts rule
there you have it five picks with great
actors and some other redeeming
qualities as well be sure to let us and
your fellow viewers know in the comments
what you did check out whether it was on
this list or not and please check out
the rt25 page at rottentominos.com so
you can vote in our fan fave movie and
TV poll voting is good that's all for
today fresh family until next week stay
fresh
foreign